e
e e
good afternoon I'd like to open up uh
Senate Bill 476 FN uh making the capital
appropriation of Department of
Corrections toward the replacement of
New Hampshire state prison for men an
apology for those that have tuned in and
viewing uh we just returned from a um a
trip to see the facility and we were
running late so I uh told the uh
committee members that we would start
the hearing at 1:15 so I'm going to
recess Senate Bill
476 uh to 1:15 which is approximately 12
minutes from
now
e
e e
I am going to uh open up the work
session we are uh fortunate as represent
Mills just reminded me um that we could
uh discuss I want to wait for the full
committee to have a conversation with
the treasurer
but if there uh were members that didn't
go on
today's uh tour or maybe you've had a
time to think about what you saw and had
some follow-up
questions not so much on the financials
but on the
operations uh does anyone have any
questions they would like to ask the uh
the prison
Administration yes please
represent kazinski yeah I was just
curious some areas I saw where there was
large amounts of paint peeling and stuff
it seemed like it was be rather simple
to scrape that and paint it you know and
give it a more attractive look I some
peries looked a little neglected on
simple maintenance I was just wondering
why that would
be sure uh good afternoon Paul Raymond
the assistant commissioner with the New
Hampshire Department of Corrections uh
appreciate the question and uh also
really appreciate the opportunity to
have most of you at the facility
today I think you know we we make uh
strong efforts and the staff makes
strong efforts to keep up with uh the
Cosmetic look of the facilities as best
as possible uh to be fair uh to our
staff I think you know it would be the
same staff that are essentially fixing
some of the maintenance issues right and
so we we end up because of our staffing
vacancy issues we end up putting a lot
on our maintenance team to to maintain
the facility and um the Cosmetic look uh
and feel inside the prison sometimes has
to take uh a seat and wait for us to fix
some of the more significant issues like
the plumbing issues or um the other
matters that that you saw across the
facility uh I think the team works hard
to try to keep up with the cosmetic
things but sometimes there's just so
much to maintain a facility that's built
in the 1800s or uh some of the facility
built in the 80s uh that we just don't
have the the Staffing to do it and and a
lot of that work would be done by the
residents but it still requires our own
staff to monitor the residents and
observe uh the work that they're
doing further
questions yes please please represent
pelie hit it one more time there
represent One More Time
Boom go to red on red thank you yay
okay it is the prison facility we have
now rated medium security or maximum
security it is it is uh a combination so
it's a multi-level security facility so
we do have medium custody residence
there and we also have maximum security
custody residents and how many prisoners
do you have for
sell uh it depends on the the custody
level but the majority of the cells uh
have two residents in them two okay and
what size of the cells uh I I don't know
the size off hand and uh
okay oh I'm just curious yeah I I'm
sorry I don't know the size off hand i'
I've been on the internet lately looking
up maximum security medium security
prisons around the country and what
they've been built for and how they've
been designed and
uh I'll I'll let it go with that thank
you
further further represent clear uh yes
thank you Mr uh um commissioner uh on
the third page in the handout you gave
us last week it turn your mic I'm sorry
Carl thank you Mr chairman uh it says
your current population is 1,28 and the
capacity is approximately 1,400 so I
assume this is still accurate correct
yes okay and then on the next page it
has the incar erated population trending
and I noticed figures the last latest
figure from 2023 is 1897 is just this
just for the Men's prison or all your
facilities please that is all facility
population okay that includes not only
the Men's prison the women's prison and
the uh Correctional Facility up in
Berlin is that correct correct and it
also includes our transitional housing
units transitional housing units thank
you yes please represent
thank you for taking my question thank
you for taking my question going through
the uh the medical part of the uh
facility it seems to me that uh a lot of
the equipment that you're using is
old how come that hasn't been upgraded
or is there a plan to upgrade it in the
new new Jail uh so prison uh it's a it's
a good question we uh we do regularly
update our our medical equipment um uh
especially when it's needed but I would
I would argue too that uh sometimes
buying new medical equipment means we
need to find space that we simply just
don't have in the current facility right
so we may end up using an x-ray machine
that uh we've had for years and years
because it still fits in the space that
we need and it's easier for us to just
get it fixed than buying a whole new uh
machine thank you further questions
I I will say a comment um I um I was in
there there are always places uh the
peeling paint and that sort of thing um
that always happen and I understand that
things can't be gotten to in a timely
manner when at a moment's notice uh the
life of view and the residents could
flip upside down in that facility I will
say that I was extreme
impressed by the cleanliness of
everywhere that we entered and I always
look down to the floor and I and I Look
to where it joins into the wall space
and I I was very impressed at how old
the structure is and how well your crew
is maintaining it I would also say I was
very impressed by um your staff and
personnel and the U the condition s that
people are working with with without air
air handling quality and temperature
controls so um we will We Will on our
side decide the
policy um but I just wanted to say with
what you're working for on Aid
structures and so forth uh I want to
commend you the wardens and and the
complete staff uh for what we saw thank
you thank you I I know you didn't ask a
question but do your mind if I respond I
would love to have you sir I should have
said would you believe um I I I just
think everything you said is a is a
testament to the hardworking staff that
we have and uh I just want to reaffirm
that we do have incredible staff we work
very hard to try to retain them and
sometimes it's a challenge given the
environment that we have but for you to
recognize the team uh and and it's not
just the commissioner and me obviously
it's really the boots on the ground team
uh I appreciate that and and um with
with your uh permission I'd like to
share this video with the team because I
think it's important for them to
recognize that you sir and the and the
committee here have recognized the good
work that they do so it it's greatly
appreciated thank you thank
you um yes represent Bo just a question
of the chair I noticed that the vice
Chairman's working off of a deck
presentation will that be made available
to the committee we got it last got
should be in your should be
all right any further
questions um at this time I would like
to uh recognize the treasurer uh please
come forward um committee is very
appreciative that you would take your
time to be here it was a request of
several
members um
we um in last year we handled Capital
Appropriations it's out of
cycle and um we recognize the need we
know that this was put in one time
before or more more than one time before
and now it's before us it's a senate
priority here and um I guess we would
like to hear if we were to try and find
$40 million at five and a half percent
that number
just just really hit me hard at five and
a half percent uh could you give us some
Reflections on this please Madam sure
thank you Mr chairman uh and thank uh
thanks to the members of the committee
for asking me to come uh today it is my
pleasure to be here um so um I
understand um I've had very limited um I
guess I will start uh saying that I've
um have very brief we had a brief
conversation in my office with the with
commissioner HS and um in another member
of her staff a few years back and we
started discussing the idea of um how to
finance a new prison so I have a a very
vague number um of about 400 million at
the time um again I don't know how those
conversations are going nowadays but
that's that's just my basic recollection
of um or that's the extent of my
discussions about this this particular
project um my my my second comment would
will be um 40 million is is a large
appropriation to be in the middle of the
bium um as you know these will add um
you already
approved 37 million for the bium so this
will be if if approved it it will turn
into a 177 million um Bond and
authorization for the banum so that kind
of uh changes the structure of how we
typically budget that service uh we
count on the idea that you will stay
within the 120
million um you know plus or minus last
time it was 137 million and then we
count on sometimes in the middle of the
banum you will approve a few small
projects and those don't typically
impact um our bond end so an
authorization of um this amount you know
it we we essentially didn't budget those
service for for this amount so we will
have to adjust that um so again those
are things that you already know um the
state does have the capacity to bond a
little more there's no doubt I think um
what I
probably and and I thank you for
bringing me to this conversation just
because this is a again a project that
will cost
[Music]
um you can't fund it all at once or you
will have to think about how you want to
finance this project whether it's going
to be over a period of several years or
how you will want to fund this project
in addition to the rest of the projects
that you already consider during the
bayum um because this particular
um so so again going back to your
question about this bill I think I I
will I I would be will normally be
concerned with an amount like this one
40 million it's not like the state can't
afford it I think the state can't afford
it um we will have to probably if we're
off with that service it would be
probably a trip for me to go to fiscal
committee and say well we may need a
little more for that service and going
forward
um again if by if if if the decisions
are that that this committee and the
legislature will move away from the
typical structure of 120
million during the banum then again we
will have to change our projections or
that sort of projections as as you all
know um the de affordability study that
we prepare our Deb projections what we
present to um to you all the legislature
to the rating agencies is all based on
that structure so um if we were to
change the structure a bit we just need
to know that and and try to bake it in
to to determine those calculations but
but again I think at one time for an
emergency reasons for a particular
reason yes it will increase that service
um um it's just it's just one of those
uh it's just this large appropriation
the mum can definitely change the
structure of how we do things so that's
my my initial comment um I think another
another point that I would like to just
um share with you is since this project
is again it's going to be costly um this
facility um I will imagine it will last
for another 100 years um so perhaps
conservation will be given could be
given to a different structure of
financing for this we typically Bond a
lot all of the coule projects are based
on a 20-year amortization schedule um
this facility again because of the life
of this this asset will be longer than a
typical asset you know a different
structure could be considered so it
could be like this particular project
could be evaluated differently than um
the rest of your projects that you
approve um you know on a regular basis I
think um again this because of the
nature of the this facility it is not a
typical Capital project it's a it's a
it's a one time project that you
probably do um I don't know when you'll
you know if you end up building this one
what will be the next one around so
again I I guess my my comment is uh I
guess a particular or different
consideration we given to to to
financing um a project like this one so
those are my initial comments again I I
think is I think is again the the the
the state can afford
well proba take take it back uh in terms
of bonding capacity I think we could
bond a little more you know the cost
based on the uh fiscal fiscal note the
cost of debt service that it will it
will add to our to our budget so you
know whether we're going to have enough
revenues to cover the debt service
that's a separate conversation I don't
have the answer right now um again
because of the way revenues are coming
in and and all of the various needs and
how the um when the operting budget was
crafted this additional bonding was not
considered so um again but in terms of
bonding capacity the state does have the
capacity to include this one time um if
you wanted to bond this for a million um
but again all of the other points that I
made I just is I think is is just so you
can consider everything um as part of
your decision of how to how to finance
this this project thank you before I
open it up to committee questions so if
if I remember
reading um whether it was our bond
rating we were we were recently upgraded
I
believe uh with with this with this 40
million dollar jeopardize any of that no
not at all I think um I think what with
the rate and upgrade um means is that
the state has done a really good job
with all of the decisions and obviously
that's thanks to all of you and your
work um in terms of you know when it
comes to capital projects and the way
that we uh we Finance uh and the state
the state has had a very
um essentially a very good policy and
practice of how how you have very low de
you know debt compared to your revenues
compared to your assets um so that you
know the way one of the that was that
that that has been one of the uh trends
of our state to have to the again the
way um the state handles um financing
and bonding um so so this will not
wouldn't jeopardize uh the rating um but
again it's all about the state has a
capacity to bond a little more right now
um it's just it will be helpful for me
to understand um again if you decide to
change our structure that we've had had
over the years and and we will just have
to take that back and and and just
consider that as as part of our future
projections of debt thank you for that
represent
B thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question I'm not sure if this question
will be towards the the chairman or to
you so I'm just gonna ask um typically
through our capital budget that we do uh
every
two
years uh it's a typically 120 million in
in that area yes so if this is approved
would it now
be 160 million or will
we see what I'm asking are we yeah I I
believe it's an additional we're not I
don't know that and perhaps you know
this I don't know the answer that I
don't believe that we're going to open
the capital budget to amend this we're
just simply looking to add a new project
and it typically would come through the
odd year which it didn't so this is high
This is highly unusual we have we had an
appropriation in to do this I believe in
the last capital budget or the budget
before and it was
removed and so now it now it appears to
the Senate that uh it's it's time to act
on this am I incorrect with it it would
be a
[Music]
new correct this would be a new capital
appropriation so is a is is so what was
already approved for the banum again we
typically recommend about 120 million
for bium but during the last bium it was
137 because it was I believe it was 120
plus another 17 million for the
University system and I remember this
committee asking me if that was okay and
and and it is always a policy decision
right but in terms terms of impacting
any of our numbers it didn't impact our
numbers so again so the capital budget
um was 137 million so this 40 will be an
addition to that for this buum yeah and
followup and looking at uh different
ways of financing such a large project
would it
be
considered uh when it wants this 40
million and to design is done and then
they go in and ask for the money to
actually build the prison could we
retake an extra 40 million and retire
that Bond early so that and wrap it up
because it's going to be a larger
expense on the actual build to the
prison and so it it it to me would make
sense You' just retire your your first
loan loan and add it to the second
larger loan
because yes thank you for that question
so we typically don't retire debt so
when we issue bonds
um generally those the for the first 10
years we can't call those bonds those we
need to maintain those bonds and pay
investors during the first 10 years
during the second 10 years if we see an
opportunity to to essentially refinance
those those loans if the rates and the
market and the conditions are
appropriate um we we are able to
consider um refunding those those bonds
so I guess the the initial your initial
question we we can't really retire for
the first 10 years during the second
years's uh during the I'm sorry during
this um last 10 years of a bond we could
again we could re refund those bonds but
only if the conditions um are are
appropriate uh for for to be able to do
that I think the other piece that I
wanted to say so the
5.5% that our chairman mentioned that
was an estimate that we typically use we
use a 5% estimate the this time around
we use a five it was it's part of our
templates when we prepar fiscal notes we
just used a
5.5% because we weren't sure how the
rates were going to behave um for the
most part
um the the rates have been okay but what
happens is we we we always pay 5% to
investors so the the coupon is always 5%
um so um just to again just a a point
relative to that rate
um thank you for that thank you yes
representative Jack thank you Mr
chairman and thank you treasure it's
always a pleasure to see you um my
question is in the same area if we were
to do this uh and then we were to get to
next year's capital budget would we
expect the 120 million recommendation to
be adjusted downward because we've done
this extra
amount good point so so it will all
depend on how you want to handle your
your policy right
so so so so again typically we we will
say around the 120 million
recommendation um you know plus or minus
um you could you you could again it just
all the depends how you want to finance
this particular project if you're going
to do it over a period of five years 10
years um you could perfectly add you
know the way the same way you do it with
the university system you can do 20
million 50 million over period of time
um you you you could potentially reduce
your 120 million and just include that
project as part of your overall capital
budget or you already will know that you
want to approve 120 million
plus an addition amount that will be um
you know targeted for this for this
project so depending on how you want to
finance this this project and how soon
it's going to be built and all of that
and again those are the details I don't
know in terms of um I haven't had a
recent conversation with Department to
to know how those those um you know that
plan is going to to to know that I guess
the the other pieces instead of um um
instead of um again my my comment about
this project being different is perhaps
it could be structured in a way that is
is it would be an a modication of 30
years rather than 20 years so you just
it's it's all about how to you know be
be a little less painful for the budget
how you pay that debt service over time
thank you further qu represent beer
thank you Mr chair and thanks for
addressing my question um in line with
uh with what the representative just
said right now if if next year you're
going to usually you caution us or you
give us advice and how you want us to do
things or how you think the governor
will like us to do
things are we going to be able to go
ahead with let's say 120 next year right
off or are you going to caution us
because before you've told us how much
debt we have it could affect our rate
and then affect our bonding and and
things so would you anticipate being
your
recommendation yeah no thank you for the
question so so again we we prepared the
Deb affordability study and um I'm I'm
not sure if you had a an opportunity to
review that study but what the study
does is e we we essentially project that
over the next four bayna you will
approve around 120 million for the banum
so so what that does it allows us to so
we project we project that you will bond
that those amounts we also project uh
revenues over time and and so we we
prepared this study where we evaluate
how Debt Service is going to look over
the next six years and and and so that
gives us an understanding of you know
how our debt is our debt service is
going to look over
time so so I guess to to answer your
question the recommendation continues to
be the same about 120 million over the
over the
vium and um but again if you want to
during your your process if you end up
bonding a little more or a little less
it won't impact our numbers that much
and I'll be happy to share that study
again with you because it really what
that does is is just it just shows our
projections um the good news about those
projections is if you as this committee
and the legislature and the governor
they always stay around those
recommendations the good news is that it
really has worked for the state like I
said based you know the rating agency
was really like our our policies our our
debt policies and and the way we've
managed our debt um and and because of
that that's the reason we you know our
ratings are are as strong as they are
today and I hope I answer your question
kind of I can follow up please thank you
um so right now if this 40 million's
included in the hund you said the 37 we
already did so that's
177 so um does that have the potential
to affect our bonding at all because
before again we've always been cautioned
about going over the minimum amount what
he does is again the the state has a
capacity to bond meaning we typically
review the the capacity based on the
revenues because revenues have been so
strong over time right now we definitely
have a capacity to bond a little more I
think the tricky part will be when
you're trying to pay that Debt Service
when it comes to the operating budget
and we want to add more Debt Service and
when we have the the other side of the
budget saying you need to stay within
this you know and this is It's it gets
paid with General funds so again that's
does you know how you pay your debt
service over time is what really should
be part of your consideration um you
know as part of you know how much you
Bond and and and like I said if you if
you you typically stay within those
recommendations it hasn't been a problem
for the state um adding more Debt
Service I'm not saying it's a problem
it's just something that needs to be
considered as part of the the next
operating budget when we have to put
that together thank you represent Mills
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question I just want to recap what I
think I've heard for the rest of the
committee and it sounded to me as if we
can take this 40 million right now and
add it to our current
137 limit without affecting any of our
ratings or any concerns about paying it
back however moving forward with our
normal
120 million bonding every by enum we
would look at this project separately
call it 500 million that it's going to
take and rather than Bond it like our
normal
120 take this and treat it separately
and still included in 120 but have the
500 million done over a 30-year a
40-year period or something like that so
it wouldn't affect us with our whole
total 120 am I close to hearing that
correctly yes that you said we should
actually consider it bonding at a
different on a different time level
different structure yes structure corre
I so yes that's correct so this you
could this this this committee and and
it could be it will be a policy decision
to treat this project separately and it
wouldn't
um that way we will know how we will
fund it over time
you you could even consider that
separately and then still stay within
120 million again I think the question
is if you wanted to take this project
and and and do it not not as part of the
capital budget um we will have to just
look at that structure and how that will
look and be added to the typical 120
million so that what you typically
review all of the multiple projects that
come before you are not impacted so yes
we could look at this project separately
and and and review the options for finan
in this project follow up yeah just a
follow up so we have
options and you think we can pay
it
um I I I will confirm that we do have
options okay how to pay it is going to
be over time and and and yes it could be
all planned and I think um you know
project like this one if if it's
structured and planned accordingly I
think again we just need to all be
knowledgeable about this including the
governor I mean perhaps additional
conversations with the governor's office
how they they thought about how to fund
this or Finance this this project you
know will be helpful but I think it will
be helpful to have this project as a
separate conversation I thank I think I
think this committee's concern was
always that we know the 40 million is
just the tip of the iceberg and what are
we going to be we don't want to just
toss 40 million and find out that we
can't come up with 500 million to finish
it so thank you very much thank you rep
shev
boy thank you Mr chairman and I don't
know if this has been addressed please
Ru me out of order if my question is
inappropriate um but the 5.5 that you
have in the bill Municipal Bond Bank
right now is 3.8 at 20 years I I chare a
trust fund where the current rate is at
at 2.8 depending on a 20 or 30 of fix
depending on the nature of the project
um for projects with this thing is it
done differently as opposed to going
through a bond bank I I got your
testimony previously that you're you're
basing it on on past experiences I guess
I'm looking at to what venue would we be
potentially be looking at at bonding yes
so we we issue the bonds the state
issues the bonds uh we use a 5%
um 5% as part of the the assumptions
because it's what it's a coer that we
pay to investors so when we budget
agencies have to consider that 5%
because that's really what we pay to
investors every time we pay de service
in term of in terms of the actual yield
what you know what you know right now we
just we just issue bonds we're actually
closing on the bonds tomorrow um the the
actual yield that we received for this
last sale was was
3.4% what that means is over time it
will really cost us about 3.4% % but
what we have to pay to investors is
5% um so that's the typical bonding
structure that we have it's just
agencies need to budget the amount that
we have to pay for thatb service um and
what that means in terms of that that
difference is
um we get to bond a little less of what
we let's say we need um $70 million in
proceeds but investors are willing to
pay as a Prem so we end up bonding or
borrowing 60 million instead so that's
the that's the difference between you
know when we want to pay a higher coupon
to investors and the actual cost of our
of our borrowing and that's that's that
actually 3.4% right now is a very good
very good uh rate thank you any further
questions U yes please represent vulner
I think it's a quick question the bonds
that we issue are they uh exempt from
federal income tax and are they exempt
from the state indd tax yes they are
okay thank you further
questions yes please thank you Mr
chairman thank you so for right now for
the for the this proposal for the
engineering architectural plans uh
programming and construction documents
we have the capacity right now for about
40 million to
bond we we could add that we we could
add it yes thank you thank you any
further questions
yes please representative kazinski
excuse me
Newton thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh first I would
like to congratulate you on the Stella
job you do with the state's finances I
feel very comfortable when you come and
testify I feel that uh very confident
that you know what you're doing thank
you um this question may or may not be
for you um when I look at the number
they're talking approximately 500
million for a new jail and 40 million
for the architectural design Etc that
seems like a rather high
percentage what is that like seven or
eight% for architectural for the $500
million plan again I'm not familiar with
the details of the plan of the cost of
the project right now does does
um so yes I will probably agree with you
um but in terms of um you know your
question maybe the department could
probably be
more helpful there follow up uh please I
just I just want to tell the
representative though that Public Works
is the opinion that that the planning is
typically 10% of the build so 10% 10% so
please Contin do do you ever when
bonding is being asked to be done do you
ever look at the numbers and say gee
some of these numbers don't quite add up
it seems rather steeper is that not your
your purview we don't typically get into
the details of the project cost um um
the Departments work with various
experts on on how to do that as part of
the capital budget process um I know the
department of administrative Services
they're all involved and over seeing the
cost the governor's office so we
typically don't get involved um you know
during that part of you know the the the
the cost of the project uh we we we are
responsible for the financing of of of
the projects um so yeah so to answer
your question we we don't get involved
in that thank you okay thank you any
further questions for the treasurer yes
please representative kazinski thank you
um just to be clear we're being asked to
approve 40 million but in I correct
understand the department of Prisons has
10 million extra in addition to this so
they're talking about spending 50
million
is that cor I I don't I don't know the
answer to that and perhaps when we're
finished with the treasurer we could we
could bring the prisons up and we'll
we'll get that answer for you is there
anything else at this point in time for
the
treasurer Madam I thank you so much for
adjusting your schedule and coming and
being with us today absolutely thank you
very much
thank you uh thank you again for coming
forward and perhaps you could ask answer
the rep representative's question yes uh
my pleasure to be back and appreciate
the question so uh House Bill two uh
originally the request was 450 million
that was reduced down to 10 million we
received 10 million in the last house
bill two and now we are seeking the rest
of that 50 million so that 50 million
would be the estimated 10 % as the
chairman said of the total cost although
prior to my testimony last week we had
gotten a number from public works at the
department of administrative Services
which put the total cost just over
600 uh 600 million so it was it it was
584 million plus the 50 million for the
design and
testing thank you is there a followup
question question represent Kinski now
that you've heard
that represent Newton if I could um does
it that just 10% that seems kind of high
you know we're working at a new Nursing
Home in straford county and the
engineering cost Etc came in at between
3.5 and
3.75% but that was only a $200 million
nursing home so it just seems like why
is this jail costing so so much more
percentage wise for what's being built I
have trouble grasping that sure I think
the I think the big reason is because it
is a prison we we are designing a a
structure that is that is not your
typical housing structure uh there are
extreme costs that go into uh designing
and uh building a prison just one
example the uh the cost today to replace
windows in our prison is $220,000 per
window um you're you're not building a
house or any residential structure at
$20,000 per
window and if if I could before I go
back to the follow-up
question um it's public works that's
pulling this this proposal together with
input from your department correct
because in the past there have been
some correct we we got the number from
Public Works that we didn't come up with
the number of how much it's going to
cost to build this present
that came from the Department of
administrative Services Public Works
okay before I do rep Jack was there a
follow-up question Gentlemen please well
um maybe this would be a little
different but while we were here
earlier um I looked up some figures and
what I see like say for instance
Nebraska they're building a 1500 bed
prison for 350 million and Alabama is
doing a 4,000 bed for 973 million
lenworth is going to get replaced the,
1400 bid with 340 sta uh 340 staff for
like 530 million so I I was just
wondering how this this 600 million
seems excessive to compared to what's
these are all maximum security
prisons I I can't speak to the the
square footage number that Public Works
gave us for the number um and I don't
know how they came up with with that
number where we're using the figure that
they gave us based off of their
estimation uh on a a price per square
foot I believe it was
1,080
$1,070 per square foot was the number
that Public Works gave us I'm sorry that
was
$170 per square foot 1,70 I was going to
say I didn't that first number didn't
sound right 1,000 thank you um and and I
will come back to you repr jack so if if
the appropriation is um for $40,000
there's $10,000 that hasn't been spent
and and during the process if if um if
the process were to go swimmingly
well um there may not there in those
there may not be a need to expend all of
those or by the end of that we might
come to a conclusion that there is an
alternative that would be less than 6
600 absolutely just as an example the
Northern New Hampshire Correctional
Facility uh was estimated to be at $39
million granted that was 25 26 years ago
uh the cost came out to about 29 million
when we were done with the or I'm sorry
at the at the end of RFP and bidding the
the cost was around 29 million so there
was a $10 million savings just as
example of that
um I will forewarn you though uh that
company did go bankrupt after building
the Northern New Hampshire Correctional
Facility thank you represent Jack uh
thank you again Mr chairman back to my
represent Jack thank you thank you do we
know uh what year the this the uh design
might be completed and you would be
ready to come back for construction
funding I don't know uh I I said on the
tour we were estimating between six and
10 years uh for for when we'd be
building a new prison but I don't know
what the time frame I think you know
that realistically how how quickly we
could do it would would come uh from the
legislature who sets that policy for us
yeah that's not actually my question if
I could okay then I misunderstood I'm
sorry the first step is to do the design
sure what year do we expect the design
to be finished and then you would ask
for construction funding gotcha we uh as
soon as we get the the 50 million we
plan to put that out and start working
on that so I would anticipate that we
would have a design uh ready for the
team within a
year okay R
shamb thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question uh the the
question I have is would you say
that when you send this out to have it
design that you have limited amount of
architectural firm terms that can design
to the level of security that is needed
for a facility like
this correct there's only there's only a
handful of companies that that uh across
the country that build and design or
design uh maximum security presence and
one followup please and would you say
that the design has to incorporate all
the conceptual lawsuits that could be uh
prevented in the
future based on the design so they're
actually trying to design out
lawsuits which would be a cost savings I
think that's certainly something we
we'll consider in the design absolutely
um uh I think you know the the biggest
issue we have right now is is we have a
facility that does not facilitate
Rehabilitation and is not Ada compant
that's one of our biggest issues that
we're running into today right uh
eliminating the ADA compliance issues
will be a huge step in the right
direction for the Department of
Corrections thank
you yes represent boy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question what is the minimum
cost to put out to request to put out
the bit to an architectural firm to
design because hb2 is already allocated
$10 million I would have thought that
the process would have already been
begun and that the additional bonding
requests is meant to amplify the next
steps in in pushing forward and in
building this new facility so I'm just
curious to know yeah I I appreciate that
question I I uh I know I've heard the
answer to it I I can't answer it myself
I'd like to call on uh somebody from the
team that I know would be able to answer
that
question yeah
good afternoon my name is Heidi laramy
I'm the administrator of logistics for
the Department of Correction so I
oversee the capital
projects um so um I'm sorry the design
so the 10 million that we were initially
allocated we are actually in the process
with an engineering firm um that
contract is in process the approval
process right now so we do have a design
firm select Ed um with the assistance of
Public Works um they assisted in finding
this firm and this firm is going to be
looking at um things like sighting site
evaluation site testing um you know what
what size we can build where it's going
to be located um so all these things are
going to be in the initial um site
design with the 10 million so the
additional 40 million will be to design
the actual structure
itself thank you
yes than Mr chairman thank thank you
could I ask you to stay seated Madam I
may have a
question from the previous question that
I hear correctly saying that once if you
get the funding the 40 million you think
within a year you'll have a set of
construction
plans hopefully within one to two years
one to two years yeah okay thank you
okay yes please represent
no yes thank you on on that same line
going back to I think it was
representative Jack who asked so how
what would be the the number of years
involved in getting a new facility done
and I didn't understand if it would be
six to 10 for completion if everything
went really terrific to get something
done so it could be on the alongside
2034 yes I think I our Target would be
we would be in a new facility and a
replacement facility within that six to
10 year time
frame okay and and in the interim while
design engineering was going on and a
new one may or may be under construction
there would still be a certain amount of
upkeep with what you've got right now
correct the handout I provided last week
outlined we anticipate in the next 10
years spending upwards of over $300
million close it of $400 million in just
Capital Improvement projects and
maintenance on the facility itself thank
you further
questions um I'm I just have a design
question and
perhaps when when when you have your
your um
study done youve you've drawn up and
you're starting to move to
construction and um I'm going to assume
we're going to stay in on the same
property we own it we have a large large
uh campus there available to us is is
there any thought that this will be
built somewhat sectional and move some
of the population in and tear down and
move some other population in because
I'm I'm worried about the the much
larger expense and that that's a more
costly Pro process I understand that but
is something like that under under
consideration we have had some of those
discussions I think the the the biggest
issue from from our standpoint is uh is
Staffing two facilities at that point
and then also uh all of the logistical
needs to operate two facilities even
though they'd be nearby um you know I
think we'd have to map out what that
would look like because the concern of
operating for example two kitchens or
two Health Care Centers or uh two
educational centers could impact our
capabilities to run any at all okay
thank you okay I want to thank you both
for appearing thank
you yeah so I will uh about a
gavel we will close this work session we
still need to uh schedu the executive
session on this this is a this is
scheduled
right executive session oh I apologize I
didn't have that in front of me okay all
right so with
that we're running a little
late so we will now move into uh the
time being 150
7 uh we will now move into the executive
session on Senate Bill 476 making a
capital appropriation Department of
Corrections toward the replacement of
the New Hampshire state prison for
men do we have a do we want to have a
discussion on where we go here or I
would be willing to accept a motion at
the same time
yes represent Newton yeah I'm uh I
didn't make the last meeting I apologize
for that I had severely flooded seller I
had to deal with um why
now why now we're almost at the end of
the
bium we've got we heard representative
wer tell us that we spent a bunch of
money we didn't have I like the fact
fact that we're bonding it is the only
thing that makes it a little different
but why are we doing this now and not
part of the next
budget my my understanding that the need
has risen to a
point um and my additional understanding
is that the $10 million that's been
appropriated is not enough to handle
that need and it's it's being brought
forward I've had I've had a convers
ation uh with representative W on wer on
this
issue and
um I've not had that comment I've not
had that return on that comment at this
time yes representative Faulkner so my
understanding is that in fact they put
this request in a year ago last year
last
term that it was originally going to be
funded out of hb2
through General funds is that correct
and they just cut that down to 10 so now
it's not really the last minute thing
it's basically going to follow up on
what was
reduced reduced appropriation last
year thank
you repent
boy thank you Mr chairman and I um I
guess I want to amplify representative
Newton's comments I I we had this place
in hb2 last year and if somebody please
correct me who's the director of
Corrections the woman that that
testified last year excuse me Helen
Helen Helen Hanks thank you commissioner
Hanks um you know we during that
testimony last year we heard a lot of we
we heard a lot of anecdotes from her and
from her staff as to the condition of
the prison we saw pictures of what the
kitchen facility looks like we've we
know that they've got um that they're
trying to repair the the sewage problem
they're trying to re reconfigure the
infrastructure that allows the the um
the uh the waste to be able to to leave
from that from that facility and not
have that situation back up
so I hate to use the word dire Mr
chairman but but we knew about this last
year we took appropriate steps we we put
the 50 million in the budget why why it
was moved I I don't know the answer to
that particular question and the the
only Redeeming Grace again to amplify
representative num now we're looking at
a bonding issue
which you know being a former Town
counselor I I would rather pay cash for
something than to whip out the credit
card that that has always been my
Approach at at having served at the
local level in tackling problems at the
municipal level and now being grown up
and sitting at this table it's it's a
little bit of a different perspective
but even still you know this this this
committee made a commitment to begin the
process by paying for a cash so I'm you
know I I understand the need I
understand that why why they're coming
to us right now I'm I'm inclined to air
on the side of what our what the good
state treasur has communicated to us I
don't think the Senate would have sent
over to us if they didn't feel that they
could uh be able to make those
particular numbers work in the grant
scheme of things but I'm I I just
publicly I don't like it because we had
the Apple presented to us last year and
and we didn't buy from the Apple last
year so that's the thing that I'm kind
of I'm kind of it's it's garring at me
right now Mr chairman is that you know
we could have we could have done the
right thing and appropriated the money
as opposed to using the credit card so
not I it's it's needed that that entire
place needs needs an overhaul I think
we're all in agreement on that um and it
should have been done years ago the fact
that we're looking at a project you know
that's looking it's going to take 10
years to to build this AT3 to $400
million we should have been should have
been doing this years ago so anyway I
appreciate you let me speak thank you Mr
chairman if I could could have should
have and we
didn't um
I they um there are there are needs in
the state um that um cost estimates that
keep coming back to us
that are enormously larger than what was
brought forward I I I think of the
ventilation system at the police
standards I think of the uh project to
replace the gondola Canon
Mountain um with the the
reason so at the same point if if we
don't move forward with good planning
now um I I I think that's one
issue we we are we are the policy
committee here and then it will go to
finance and finance then will have will
have their say whether at that point in
time uh it's something they they want to
back or not back and then and then the
proposal will come back to us at the
house and we will we will then cast our
our second vote on it so I I myself am
not happy to be looking at a capital
appropriation in the second year here
but but things happen and this is one
this is this is one of those that uh uh
we are going to consider whether we do
that today or whether we postpone this
decision another day or so but it's also
an early bill um that we need to uh to
move out of here so that it can go to
finance I would prefer to continue the
discussion and then I'm going to call
for a caucus before we go any further
than this represent boy I was going to
move approval and I'll follow your lead
Mr chairman thank you re shamon I'll
come back to the other uh yes I I will
say that
um the I don't like what's going on
here but because of my faith in the
treasur and saying that it's not going
to be the end of the world if we do it
and if you feel we have to do it I will
support the passing it on to the finance
but I disagree that where we are a
policy committee but as a representative
as a conservative representative money
matters to me and I like to see it spent
well and spent the best for all of my my
constituents and that's a job we all
have and that's why there's great
hesitancy on my part but I will tell
everybody I will will support bringing
this forward at this time come back to
you represent jur did you have a
comment my general comment that the
treasurer did state that right now at
what
5.5% uh we could do we could bond this
40 million and for the needs that we've
everybody has discussed so far and for
the uh for the history of what's been
going on and knowing again with every
how when this should have been done and
what you just said in ition going
forward they're planning on spending 300
million more to for maintenance and uh
and Bas and bandages in a sense to keep
the facility going and one final thing
bringing prospective employee in there
to look around for for a Corrections
job uh is probably a difficult task uh
it's you know you can you can feel what
you want about the residents there but
we have state employees that have to
show up there every day with the
mandatory at times over time time and
trying to find new employees and having
a new facility will be able to attract
new Corrections personnel and may be
able to reduce the overtime May so I'll
leave I'll leave it at that thank you r
f wanted to add that we've been talking
about $120 million for as long as I've
been here and that's been eight years
over that period of time construction
costs have gone up stock market Market's
gone up our tax base has gone
up if we're still talking about 120 it
means we're we're we're we're buying
less each year and if this is what kind
of causes us to rethink that $120
million limit I think that's high time
but I think I don't think we're gon to I
don't think it's good for the state to
be spending less and less in terms of
real buying power each year on investing
in our future so I'm I'm quite
comfortable with this addition repent
berer I was just going to make the same
kind of comment was do we include this
in that 120 or do we expand
120 to
the 140 150 cap uh is that part of all
this decision also is that a side
decision that's that's a that's future
and finance will will take up that
question going forward we have we have
in past years uh the university system
and I I won't have the right numbers for
you but keep I think was their last
project and it
was0 or $120 million and that
appropriation was broken out over over
three banum or longer and so that number
was plugged in and it was it's it's one
of those outstanding obligations that's
sitting out there like this 40 million
will be that the treasurer will then try
and reel in at at what that number and
we and and this is lame in conversation
so I apologize I know how to dig in the
ground and get employees to go somewhere
the um the $120 million is a floating
number we were fortunate as can
be to have so much arpa funds and
everything else this time I I would
predict those days are gone and we are
and we are getting to a point going
forward that it's going to become a much
more difficult decision what we spend
our money in when we our needs are here
and our amount of money to work with
here it's the same thing with our
roadways so I I wouldn't be hung up on
that right now but that is going to
become the much the much greater to me
the treasurer saying we can stretch and
we can do it but it it would be like me
sitting here and saying next year or
whoever is sitting in this fine chair
right here to say well if we if we could
go from 120 and we pushed it we added 17
million onto it but because over the
years it's it's ebed and flowed uh but I
wouldn't want to be sitting here saying
we can keep adding $40 million so uh I'm
I'm not worried about that point the
treasurer is going to do even a better
selling job to keep us afloat here so
with that further comment repr clud okay
thank you a question of the
chair just to clarify we let's say we
pass this bill today and the house for
gives it preliminary approval then it
goes to finance so and assuming Finance
looks at it and decides to go with it
then we've approved 40 million for
design now the question is that design
work will take a while to do do you
anticipate that next year for the
capital budget those of us return are
going to have possibly have to struggle
with how or or if it's not next year the
following year because we're in the off
year how to do the rest of the prison
construction project uh so in other
words may looking at something outside
the regular in
2026 depending on how things go
I represent clud I think that's that's a
fair fair
assessment um this challenge is a huge
number and I and I think the treasurers
laid it out well we could we could not
fit this into our regular budget and
it's it's going to take uh it's going to
take greater minds not only in our house
but those people on the other side to
pull this together uh think think back
to um uh the money U the four four Cent
increase in the gas tax and how we we we
term that funding which allows us Runs
Out in
2026 and I apologize for not having that
Senate bill in front of me but by only
paying the interest and not paying the
principal we benefited instead of 250 to
500 miles of uh reconstruction or
repaving of roads and bridges and
everything else it's going to take
far-reaching
policy to get us there because you know
we can't absorb this and I so we're
we're we're coming that time rep Mark so
a followup so you probably may be
looking at and I know talking with the
treasurer and listening to her we could
maybe have to finance this at least over
a 20 to 30 year and 40e period that
sounds like what would be to me
depending on I I I I think that
discussion's open and that that very
well may be represent Jackie thank you
I'll just remind everyone that the way
we do B we don't once bonding's
authorized we don't immediately jump out
and sell those bonds the treasure
determines based on cash flow when we
need to issue bonds we typically only do
it once a year and that covers the cash
flow that's required so it's not let we
people shouldn't be thinking that we're
immediately going to go out and bond the
5% thank you represent Ms I just got one
other thing and it goes back to
representative fauler saying for eight
years we've been kicking this can down
the road back to when Marty and I first
got on this committee and went to the
prison if we would have acted on it back
then that 10 years we would now be at
the ribbon cutting of the new prison
today instead of even considering this
now so keep in mind everything we do
today is is all about moving this
project forward and getting it finished
thank
you further further uh questions
comments boy move
approval I move I Mr chairman I move
that we approve Senate Bill 476
FN as ought to pass I Mr chairman
weren't we goingon to caucus yeah I I'm
I'm I'm not going to accept that motion
at this time uh what I would like to do
and thank you for the energy and thank
you for the second I would like to uh
take a five minute caucus so that we can
speak to our members and when we come
back from that hopefully we will move to
a motion I totally agree M chair so make
sure we're I don't know that you have a
we could ask our guests to move and you
folks is here and we'll go into my
office that's okay yeah okay so we'll
stay here
democr
e
e e
okay I would like to uh continue on with
the time being uh
2:31 uh continue on with the executive
session on Senate Bill 476
FN um and um I would be willing for a
motion motion by
Boyd represent bone
okay um motion well let's go with the
motion
first your motion
is ought to pass is it yes it is Mr
chairman okay do we to from that
Peterson still hasn't come back oh where
yeah ref I'm sorry I don't know where
Peter he had to get some water okay we
will um we will hold for a moment
send security to the
hall Mr take the chains chains and cuffs
oh there he
is second by
balone a motion's been made by Boy
second by balone for ought to pass on
Senate Bill
FN if you're in favor is is there
discussion Mr chair uh I say I urge this
entire committee to vote on the pass I
just emphasize we need to do this we
probably should have done it earlier but
we have so many other needs and I've
been I didn't go today but I've been
through three times and I definitely
think something needs to be done so I
urge a yes vote on ought to pass pleas
thank you thank you um thank you R
cluder
um yes R boy I just want to Echo the
clicks previous comments about let's
let's move this forward and let's let's
let's get
started from when representative Mills
was here eight years ago and probably
would be cutting a ribbon right now
so 12 years okay and representative
thank you any further discussion before
I call the role if you in favor of the
motion of ought to pass for Senate Bill
476 FN you will signify by saying yes or
or I and if you're opposed to that
motion nay or no with that would the
clerk call the role thank you Mr chair
representative cluder
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative fedolfi
representative Newton
yeah representative
kazinski representative
Boden representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin
no representative bogert yes
representative Connor no representative
Jack yes representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar
hi representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton is excused representative Peterson
yes representative vone
I representative jurus yes chairman
mccon chairman votes I Mr chair the
motion ought to pass carries 154
um thank you um I would
um um it'll be placed on the regular
calendar and we will send this along to
um
anybody is is there um is anyone wish to
write a Minority
Report seeing none okay all right so uh
we'll need to pull that together
represent Boyd in a very short fashion
within the next couple days yes sir
yes Mr chairman and um I want to um I
believe that concludes our business for
today I want to thank you for taking the
time to be here there thank you Mr